en el diagrama de arriba el segmento de
recta a de intersec a ave y el segmento
de recta a ave es paralela a d
cuál es la longitud de la 12a así que
queremos encontrar la longitud de la 12
en amarillo ahora puedas darte cuenta
inmediatamente que el triángulo pequeño
de la izquierda será semejante al
triángulo grande de la derecha pero
vamos a probarlo para estar seguros para
ayudarnos a probarlo necesitamos
recordar que ave está es paralela a d
y para pensar en eso voy a extender los
segmentos para que veamos con claridad
que son paralelas además hay dos
transversales que intersectan estas dos
paralelas y podríamos seguir extendiendo
estas rectas en ambas direcciones pero
lo importante es notar que estas dos
rectas son paralelas
esto nos ayudará a establecer que estos
dos triángulos son semejantes
lo primero que sabemos es que este
ángulo es opuesto por el vértice a este
otro así que son congruentes
si piensas además que el segmento de
recta es transversal a estas dos rectas
paralelas entonces este otro ángulo este
de aquí es alterno interno con este otro
ángulo que tenemos acá
ambos son alternos internos y por lo
tanto son congruentes si algo de todo
esto te suena un poco agregó y no eres
griego te encargo que vean los videos
sobre ángulos sobre transversales o
sobre rectas paralelas en khan academy y
por el mismo argumento si piensas en ade
como una transversal entre dos paralelas
entonces este ángulo en color verde es
alterno interno con este otro ángulo por
lo tanto son congruentes el punto
importante de todo lo que hice fue
mostrar que los tres ángulos del
triángulo pequeño son congruentes con
los tres ángulos del triángulo más
grande por lo tanto estos triángulos son
similares
y la razón del por qué esto es útil es
que si dos triángulos son similares
entonces la razón entre sus lados
correspondientes será la misma
por ejemplo la razón entre la 12 y la
longitud del segmento c
y el lado este que sabemos que es de 7.5
es la misma razón entre el lado
correspondiente en el triángulo pequeño
observa que es el lado opuesto al ángulo
en verde por lo tanto en el triángulo
similar el lado que supuesto el ángulo
en verde es el segmento psc así que será
igual a la razón entre el lado
correspondiente en el triángulo pequeño
que es 2.1 y el lado correspondiente a d
en el triángulo pequeño observa que es
el lado opuesto al ángulo en azul a uno
de los ángulos opuestos por el vértice
por lo tanto en el triángulo pequeño
similar
lado correspondiente que es opuesto al
ángulo en azul es el segmento ave así
que tenemos 2.1 / 2.5 por lo tanto cuál
es la longitud de la 12 y bueno existen
varias formas de resolverlo una de ellas
es multiplicar de ambos lados por 7.5
estos dos se cancelan y cuál es el
resultado de 7.5 entre 2.5 bueno 75
entre 25 es 3
entonces 7.5 entre 2.5 es 3
entonces el lado ce es igual a 2.1 por 3
y ya puedo decir que la longitud de la
6.3 y puedes ver que en efecto es una de
las opciones